Jason in terms of being polarizing or or
beyond that what else did you learn from
that experience that maybe wouldn't work
today I realize you can't orchestrate
something to go viral and yeah it's a
matter of timing right so yeah what
would work today that that that worked
back then and what wouldn't work I think
I think all of the factors that that
made that movie succesful would work
today because we were on the cusp of
when you could mark it on the internet
and actually sell movies on the Internet
so the technology was there was still a
little bit primitive but it was there
the thing I would have done differently
you can't orchestrate a movie and make
it go viral but if you're fortunate
enough to have some people that are out
there talking about your movie the
things i would do today is I would go
out there and become part of the
conversation and really get to know
people that are talking about it click
on a forum on a blog on all these
different places where if there's
mentioned in the movie I think I would
be there saying hi you know even if it's
jimmy and Sue's blog you've never heard
of I'd still want to give that some
credence and I understand if you go
really really viral that that may not be
quite as easy because you're on a
gazillion websites but the biggest
lesson I learned and all that was email
capture capturing email and building a
relationship with your audience not just
for the movie you're working on today
but all movies going forward and the
reason I say email and I'm not
mentioning some of the social media out
there although there's some importance
to it is because once you have the email
address it's something that you control
I you know you mentioned early on that I
that I did a lot of marketing on myspace
and that's true and I still every once
in a while go back to my profile and
look at it and it's and it's just it's
almost like a part of me that's stuck
forever in time you know what I mean
there's nothing happening on my profile
except i think they redid the site
recently looks really good yeah
I haven't been you know haven't really
engaged anything on there but anyway
social media aside we know that
sometimes it goes out of vogue email
addresses you know even though some
things are changing about email inboxes
and engagement it's still to this day
one of the easiest and most personal
ways that you can build a relationship
with somebody because it's going
directly into their inbox and even if
they ignore you they probably won't
ignore all of your emails and they're at
least seeing that that you're trying to
engage with them as opposed to like
posting a tweet or an update on facebook
where only a small percentage of people
are actually going to see what it is you
posted so what do you say to those
people who kind of live on Twitter and
Twitter is a great place to meet people
from all over the world and have fun
conversations and and at Google+ and all
that but but do you really at the core
of it you feel the email capture is the
best way yeah I feel that email captures
the best way I know there's people out
there that would say you know they'd say
I gave up my website I don't even have a
URL i don't i just have a twitter
account or I just have a Facebook
account and I think that's great I just
from my perspective I just think there's
more of an intimacy to email and I think
you know if you look at the stats for
engagement you sent it to some buddies
in boxing you know there's a very high
percentage a very high percentage of the
time that's going to end up in their
inbox we said that we doubt hoping that
somebody sees it it's a it's a much
lower percentage that says that they've
actually seen your messaging I think
Twitter and Facebook and all the
different social media both before and
now and in the future are all going to
be vitally important but I think there
should be centralized hub where you can
say okay this is my my place for
communication my hub you know my central
location and then then you can kind of
tweet out an email and communicate from
there but you have it you have access to
all the people that at least at some
point expressed interest in your work
do you believe in that sort of an amount
of loss for words but the email where
you can't access the site I'm sorry the
website where you cannot access the site
until you get their email address or
where you give them sort of a choice
like great you can come to my site but
if you want to go a step beyond and I'll
give you something for free that's
valuable yeah what what sure do you
think force people to give him your
email address or give them a choice and
they feel more at ease and giving me
that yeah so so you know the question is
like how do you get people to opt-in or
how do you share your content with
people and I think and the focus is do
you do you make them opt-in by giving
you their email address or do you just
let them see your stuff and hope that
they come back later and build that
relationship with you I'm of the opinion
that that and here's my perspective on
it when you give away really really good
content and people get to know you it
reminds me a lot of what that experience
was on our first movie where we had a
hundred thousand people coming to our
website but they never returned and they
may have wanted to return but they got
distracted with their life their bills
their family all the other kinds of
things you know that we all get
distracted with as humans so I think
that giving away something to get an
email address is in principle a really
good opportunity for you to not only
share value by giving something away
that's so awesome and so valuable but at
the same time the value is you can
always reach out to that person later
and say hey I got this new thing if you
like that thing you're going to love
this thing and I think you know I think
a lot of businesses live and die by that
philosophy not the least of which is
what we're doing a chill to help at the
company i'm working at chill to help
filmmakers this thing called insider
access where we've created an exclusive
environment for people that really love
a movie they can go in and they just opt
in and now the filmmaker has their
contact information and then the fan of
the movie gets all this exclusive
content that they can't get anywhere
else where it becomes lopsided and a
little bit derogatory in these examples
is when you got somebody that just grabs
an email address and doesn't prove to be
valuable at all
all they do is just give away stuff
that's like hey come by my thing or come
by this thing or come by that thing and
that's not at all what I'm talking about
what I'm talking about is like
permission based marketing they come to
you they're interested so they'll flirt
with you by giving you an email address
you better give them stuff that's beyond
belief because if you do that then you
build that relationship with people and
they come back for more if you don't do
that very quickly you'll get a lot of
unsubscribes and suddenly your name
you're suddenly you're that guy and you
don't want to be that guy
you